[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: Well, thank
you very much for inviting me.
I've been hearing about
some of the other talks
that you've had.
And I think they probably
all sound very much more
interesting than public health.
It can seem to be a
bit of a dry topic,
but it's also a
very broad topic.
And so I thought I'd
start by asking you,
what comes to your mind when
somebody says "public health?"
What sort of things
do you think of?
AUDIENCE: Flu injections.
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE:
Flu injections?
Yes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Spread of
dangerous diseases--
spread of communicable disease.
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: Yes,
infectious diseases,
communicable diseases.
AUDIENCE: Education on the
importance of exercise.
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: Education
on the importance of exercise.
Well, this is a very
well-informed audience.
These are all public
health topics.
And just to give you an idea
of the breadth of the area,
this is a diagram, which
was done some years ago
by some public health academics.
It's called the Rainbow Diagram.
They're talking about the
determinants of health.
And these are all the
things which affect health--
lifestyle factors, social
and community networks,
general socioeconomic
environmental conditions,
with all sorts of
subsets under that.
So all of those potentially
come under the topic
of public health.
So just to try and segment
it a little bit more,
it could be services,
systems, institutions.
So it could be in
local government.
It could be in the
National Health Service.
It could be in a health
education agency,
advising you about what
you should be doing.
It could be a public
health profession.
Back in history, it was the
medical officer of health.
Nowadays, it might
be the director
of public health locally, or
it might be, in this country,
the Chief Medical Officer.
Some of you will have heard
of Dame Sally Davies who
is often in the media.
Well, she's our Chief Medical
Officer in this country.
She's the public health
supremo In the United States,
it would be the Surgeon General.
Then another way of thinking
about public health,
it can be a form of
knowledge, a way of thinking.
And so it could be
focused on a topic,
like nowadays,
obesity or smoking.
Or it can be broader, thinking
about individual behavior
and the individual's
responsibility
for their own health.
Or even broader still,
thinking about inequality
in society and how to deal with
that and the effects of that
on health.
Or it can be thinking about
things like the environment
and housing.
So very many topics come
under public health.
And the point that I wanted to
make today, being a historian,
is that time also affects public
health, because public health
has not always been the same.
The things that have been
focused on within public health
have changed over time.
And that's what I
want to primarily
talk about today, because
it is a very huge topic.
And so I'm going to look at the
development of public health
in the past, how
we've got to where
we are in the
present day, and I'm
going to very briefly look at
the past from the 19th century
onwards.
But I'm going to focus
on four stages, really
since the Second World War--
the rise of a variant
of public health
called social and
community medicine.
Then in the '70s, the rise
of lifestyle-- the focus
on lifestyle and
also on evidence,
one way and the other,
in public health.
Then on different versions
of public health-- health
promotion, new public
health, primary health care.
And then finally, I'll
finish up by looking
at some of the recent
changes and directions
and where we might be going.
Well, going back to the 19th
century and up until the 1940s,
just very briefly to sketch
in how public health changed
in those years, if
we'd been talking
about public health
in the 19th century,
we would have been talking
about housing, the environment,
and in particular,
about sanitation.
Public health meant
drains, because for much
of the 19th century, sanitation
drains were really absent.
You will have read or heard
about the conditions as they
applied in large cities--
cities like London,
the new industrial
cities like Manchester--
which were built
without much by way
of the provision of
public facilities,
so houses that had no
sanitation whatsoever.
So the key focus of public
health in the 19th century
was getting sanitary provision.
It was an
environmental movement.
But then by the end of the
19th century, change came.
There was the Bacteriological
Revolution-- the discovery
that specific agents
caused disease.
And so disease could
be dealt with not
by changing the environment, but
by dealing with the individual
who was diseased.
So lots of treatments came
in for different diseases--
for cholera, for
typhoid, and so on.
Then in the early 20th century,
public health changed again.
There was a big focus at that
time on the hereditary nature
of diseases.
People were thinking about
disease as being inherited.
And they were focusing
on topics like alcohol.
Alcoholism was seen
as something that
was inherited from one
generation to the next.
They were focusing on
sexually transmitted disease,
which was also
seen as transmitted
through the generations.
And so the focus
of public health
came to be on women
as mothers and what
was called, in the
terminology of the time,
the future of the race.
That seems to be a very
rather eugenic sort
of terminology nowadays.
But that was the language
at the turn of the 19th,
the early 20th century.
And then finally, in
the interval years--
the 1920s and the 1930s--
public health really
expanded its remit.
And the public
health practitioners,
the medical officer
of health would
be running not just preventive
services and health education
services, but also
running hospitals
and running health
services more generally.
They took over running
health services,
in particular in London.
The London County Council
was very well-known
for its public health services.
So I want to focus on
what happened next.
And what happened next was a
big change for public health.
And it developed
a new terminology.
It became called social
medicine or community medicine.
Now why was this?
It was because new challenges
developed for public health
after the Second World War.
It had confidently
been expected when
people were talking about the
need for a national health
service that that national
health service would
be focused on public health.
It was intended
to be, originally,
a local
government-focused service
run by public health
practitioners--
the medical officer of health.
Well, that didn't happen.
We had the service that we've
got today in this country--
the National Health Service--
which is a much more
centralized service
not founded on public health.
And so there was a need for
a new role for public health.
And that caused a certain
amount of concern.
Now another reason why there
was a new role for public health
was that the whole pattern
of disease, morbidity,
and mortality in the
population was changing.
So just have a look
at this graph here.
And you can see some of the
changes that were taking place.
This is a graph from
1917 onwards up to 2007.
So it's a 90-year period.
But I think you can see
broadly the changes that
are taking place.
The green line at the bottom,
which is infectious disease,
is declining very rapidly.
Just before and after the Second
World War and into the 1950s,
it's almost gone
nowhere, really,
from being quite important.
And the other diseases--
cancer, which is the dotted,
black line--
and circulatory diseases also
becoming proportionately more
important.
So this was the change
which was happening just
before and after the
Second World War.
It was what was called the
epidemiological transition,
which was basically, the
old infectious diseases
were in decline.
The role of public
health had been
to deal with some
of those diseases.
And what was becoming much
more important were the chronic
diseases-- the sort of diseases
that we think about nowadays--
cancer, heart
disease, and so on.
And across Europe-- and in
particular, in this country--
there had been
this establishment
after the war of
new health systems,
but systems which were very
much focused on hospitals
and focused on sickness.
People always said about
the National Health Service,
it was a sickness service
rather than a health service.
And public health, which had
been much more than that--
it had been about
preventing sickness,
as well as dealing with it--
seemed to have lost its role.
And so people started
to talk about what role
it could have in the future.
And one of those roles,
which still, I think, echoes
down to the present
today, was something
called social medicine.
And this was a very broad vision
amongst some public health
practitioners just before and
after the Second World War.
This is a quote here from
one of the main practitioners
of social medicine-- a
man called John Ryle--
who was professor of social
science at Oxford University
in the 1940s.
And he said social medicine
was the "whole economic,
nutritional,
occupational, educational,
and psychological opportunity
or experience of the individual
or the community."
So you can see that's
a very broad vision.
It's not just talking
about people's
economic circumstances,
but it's talking
about their mental health, too.
It's talking about psychology.
And it's not just talking
about the individual.
It's talking about the
individual in relation
to the community
where they live.
Very broad vision indeed--
so it was very much health
seen as a positive condition
and also an attempt
to try and bring
greater academic credibility
to public health as well.
So that was one vision
which people hoped,
in the public
health field, might
form the basis of the
way health was conceived
and the way health
services were oriented
in the post-war period.
But what happened
instead was something
which was a slightly more
limited vision-- something
called community medicine.
And one of the
key proponents was
a man called Jerry Morris,
who was one of my colleagues
at the London School of
Hygiene and Tropical Medicine.
He lived until the age of 99.
And he was still coming into
work two or three days a week.
So he only died about
six or seven years ago.
But Jerry was one of
the key proponents
of community medicine.
He wrote in the
late 1950s a book
called "Uses of
Epidemiology," which talked
about public health doctors--
and they all were
doctors at this stage--
moving into the
National Health Service
as consultant
community physicians.
And in the Health Service, they
would undertake something which
he called community diagnosis.
So they would be the people who
looked to the population, who
worked out what the
needs of that population
were, in terms of sickness and
prevention and healthy living,
and they would help formulate
the way in which health
services were
structured and provided.
And the key discipline
in all of that
was going to be risk factor--
epidemiology.
So this variant of epidemiology
was the new science
of this new style
of public health.
So that's, in effect, what
happened to public health
in this country.
It moved into the
National Health Service.
And only recently, as
we'll hear later on,
has it come out of the
National Health Service.
And this was all part
of a changing focus
within public health
towards lifestyle
and also towards using evidence
in a consistent sort of way.
So the move was away
from infectious disease--
something causing a mass
pandemic or epidemic--
towards individual behavior
and lifestyle choices
as the cause of ill health.
And the key research,
which I think set the tone
for all of that,
was the research
about the relationship between
smoking and lung cancer,
which was done by
an epidemiologist
and a statistician, Richard Doll
and Sir Austin Bradford Hill.
Both of them, just by chance,
working at my own institution--
London School of Hygiene
and Tropical Medicine.
But I did know Richard
Doll, because he also
lived a very long time.
I didn't know Bradford Hill.
But they did this research in
the late 1940s, early 1950s.
And originally,
interestingly, they
hadn't thought that
smoking was the cause
of the rise in lung cancer.
They thought it might
have been something
to do with the
roads being tarred
and the fumes that were
given off by that happening.
So they were quite
surprised when
they discovered
that there seemed
to be an association
between smoking
and the rise in lung cancer.
And this was carried forward
by a very important report,
which was published by the Royal
College of Physicians in 1962--
picture up there,
Smoking and Health.
And again, that
committee which produced
this report of the Royal
College of Physicians
had originally been a committee
on smoking and air pollution.
But they decided that smoking
was a much easier issue
to deal with than air pollution.
And so they decided to focus
their report on smoking.
And of course, air pollution
has now come back to haunt us.
So epidemiology lay
behind all of this--
the element of risk
in populations.
But what also developed--
and I'll be showing
you an example
of this in a little while--
was a completely different
style of public health
using mass media campaigns
to try and change behaviors,
speaking to the
whole population,
and trying to make
the population change
their lifestyle and
change their behavior.
Well, another offshoot
of this change
in public health in
the post-war period
was a focus on health
services research
and the role of evidence.
And this was another offshoot
from social medicine.
Some of the social
medicine pioneers
moved off in a
different direction,
trying to make health services
more effective and more
efficient.
And a key person
in that area was
a man called Archie Cochrane.
Some of you may have heard of
something called the Cochrane
Collaboration,
which still is very
active in the public health
and the health field.
Archie Cochrane was a
social medicine advocate
who undertook random--
he was a prisoner of war
during the Second World War.
He was in Japanese
prisoner of war camp.
And he occupied himself by doing
randomized controlled trials
of diet amongst the prisoners
in his prisoner of war camp.
And after the war, he
was a great proponent
of using evidence in
a more effective way
to try and get the right
outcomes in health.
And he gave a very
famous lecture--
the "Rock Carling Lecture"--
in the early 1970s.
And this led to a book
which is still cited today,
"Effectiveness and Efficiency--
Random Reflections
on Health Services,"
which was trying to move
away from individual clinical
impressions as the basis
for treatment and the basis
for action in health
towards a much greater use
of a considered evidence.
And of course, the gold
standard of that evidence
was the randomized
controlled trial,
which is still very much
central to public health
and health services
more generally.
But meanwhile, public health
was adopting this new style
of mass media campaign.
And I'm just showing this as
an example of a campaign which
was run in the early 1970s by
a new agency called the Health
Education Council.
Now I don't know if
you've got ideas of what
might be different about this.
I've given you a
little clue earlier on.
Some things are rather different
about this sort of campaign.
But some things are
similar to things
in the past of public health.
Can you think of anything
that's different here?
I know this is hard, because
you're not history students.
AUDIENCE: Very graphic.
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: It's
very graphic, yeah.
It's using shock, isn't it?
Maybe you're not shocked now.
We're used to nudity.
But certainly in
the early 1970s,
I think this was unusual
for a health campaign.
So it's using shock to
attract your attention,
to try and change your behavior.
AUDIENCE: Nowadays, we
wouldn't put so many words
on the poster.
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Nowadays, we
wouldn't put so many words
on the poster.
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: That's true.
Yeah.
But then it was quite
limited in terms of words.
AUDIENCE: It's very
accusative as well.
I feel nowadays, it
would be more soft
and advisory, rather than
straight-on aggressive.
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: Yeah.
It's pointing the finger
and saying, you're to blame.
Isn't it?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's true.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The text is less
legible in the essential parts.
Today's cigarette packets
have big, big, red letters--
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: Yes.
Yeah, that's true.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't highlight
the "smoking kills" part.
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE:
No, that's true.
Well, it's a different subject
for a public health poster.
Before the war,
it might have been
things like, well, cleanliness
or preventing infection
or something like that.
So having a smoking-focused ad--
I know nowadays this
is nothing new--
but in the 1970s, it was
quite new to have this sort
of campaign around smoking.
And the Health Education Council
was spending a huge amount
of money in the '70s
just on smoking and using
the mass media.
The other interesting
thing about--
well, many interesting
things about this ad--
but it was produced for the
Health Education Council
by an agency,
Saatchi and Saatchi,
who obviously went on to
greater things after this.
But Saatchi and Saatchi
first made their name
in the health education field.
And they're bringing those
advertising techniques--
American advertising
techniques, really--
and the art of persuasion
into the public health field.
But interestingly-- and I don't
expect you to pick up on this--
they are using a very
old-fashioned topic,
aren't they, because
they're using women
as the ones who are
at fault, and they're
using women as mothers.
So women are the people
who are producing
babies who are going to be
affected by their smoking.
So women are being blamed.
Now I have to say, this
is a very common theme
within public health.
And it certainly
goes back to the turn
of the 19th, 20th century when
we had that theme of women
as mothers.
So there are some
new things here,
but also, there are some
very old things, too.
And that has continued, I think.
But public health also
continued to redefine itself.
And I want to talk about just
three other definitions--
health promotion,
new public health,
and primary health care.
And this came out of a period
in the 1970s, 1980s of an attack
on mainstream medicine.
I mentioned that after
the Second World War,
there was a great focus
on health services,
on high tech medicine.
Public health seemed
to have lost its role.
Well, by the time of the 1970s,
that enthusiasm for high tech
medicine had gone, and it had
gone for a number of reasons,
I think.
Firstly, because
of the rising costs
of health care after the oil
crisis in the early 1970s.
And people began to
think, do we really
need all these expensive
centralized health services?
Should we be trying
to think of lower cost
ways of preventing ill
health in the population
rather than dealing
with poor health
when it gets to a
crisis situation?
So that was one strand.
But the other strand was a
critique of medicine itself,
saying, did it
actually do any good?
And this is something that all
sorts of disciplines joined in.
The sociologists
were there and also,
the social medicine people.
A key leader in this was a
man called Thomas McEwen,
who was professor of social
medicine at Birmingham
University.
And he wrote this book,
which I've got up here,
"The Role of Medicine--
Dream, Mirage, or Nemesis?"
and basically argued
that official medicine--
orthodox medicine, high
tech interventions--
did much less good than
improving the general health
of the population.
And so this was obviously
leading right into a renewed
role for public health.
And three variants of public
health came on the agenda
in the '70s, '80s, '90s.
The first was
primary health care,
which was given its
seal of approval
through the declaration
of Alma Ata in 1978,
which was a desire to
move out of the hospital
into the provision of primary
health care services--
services at the community level.
And then that got mired
into debates between,
was it best to have horizontal
primary health care, which
was basically a broad vision
of health services and systems,
or was it better to have
vertical primary health
care, which would be
primary health care
focused on a few conditions?
And that was something which
obviously appealed much more
to international donors who
became important in this area.
Then there was a variant
called health promotion.
And that came through a number
of documents-- the WHO's
"Health for All" and
also, the "Ottawa Charter
for Health Promotion"
in the 1980s.
And I think that's a point to
make about this initiative.
There was a very strong Canadian
influence in health promotion.
And I've got off on the slide
there a report which came from
the Canadian Minister of Health,
Marc Lalonde, in the '70s--
"A New Perspective on the
Health of Canadians"--
which was very much focused on a
whole person, whole environment
and community
approach to health.
And then there was
something called
new public health, which was
a kind of medical version
of health promotion.
And that attracted a
certain amount of criticism,
because people felt that
public health should
be a multi-disciplinary
initiative.
And so there was a
push internationally,
but in particular,
in this country,
to try and get something called
multi-disciplinary public
health.
So nowadays, if you want
to undertake public health
as a career, you don't have to
be medically qualified anymore.
So they were quite successful
in that initiative.
Well, what's happened recently?
Let's finish off by
talking about some
of the things which
are now on the agenda.
Well, one of the interesting
things that's happened--
and it's very much visible.
There's stuff in the
papers today about the EU
is going to prosecute I think
the British government, number
of cities across Europe,
well exceeding the EU's air
pollution levels.
And London, I think,
exceeded them in the--
limits for the whole year,
exceeded in the first five
days of the new year of 2017.
So the environment,
which has really
been out of public
health for a while--
it's been very much
lifestyle and behavior--
has come back into public
health with a bang.
And that's happened in a
number of different ways.
There was the
issue of acid rain.
Everyone was talking about
acid rain for a while.
Then there was concern about
nuclear fall-out-- fall-out
from nuclear tests.
Then, of course, climate
change has come on the agenda.
And now people are
talking very much
about cities and air pollution.
And even the behavioral
public health issues
have now got their
environmental emphasis
and think of smoking and passive
smoking and the way in which
we've now got
controls on smoking
in public, smoking
in restaurants,
and even, I think,
smoking in cars now,
although I'm not sure
that that gets enforced--
smoking in cars when you've
got a child with you.
So air pollution, which
I think people thought
had been dealt with by the
Clean Air Act in the 1950s,
has come back onto the agenda in
a big way in the 21st century.
And I think other things have
come back onto the agenda, too.
Everyone confidently expected
that infectious disease
had gone away.
But from the 1980s
onwards, I think
it's been very obvious that
infectious disease hasn't
gone away.
We still have HIV/AIDS.
Then there was BSE.
There was SARS, flu of various
types-- swine flu, avian flu--
and then more recently,
Ebola and Zika.
And I think those last
two draw our attention
to something that's very obvious
in present-day public health--
that it's very much of a
global health enterprise.
Obviously, people still
operate at the national level.
But there's a whole global
arena of public health there
which is increasingly important.
And there have been attempts
to try and achieve things
at a global level.
You may have read about
the Millennium Development
Goals which were promulgated
at the time of the millennium
in 2000, and they just
came to an end in 2015.
And some of those
goals were achieved.
I think the one on
malaria was achieved.
But other ones weren't.
And so people in the
public health field
are always optimistic.
They're not discouraged.
And so now we've got
a new set of goals--
the Sustainable
Development Goals--
and a further period during
which some of those goals
may be achieved.
And one of the
concomitance of those goals
and that global set-up is
the very important role
played by international
donors and donor agencies
and organizations in
the global health field.
Now historically, that was
the case with the Rockefeller
Foundation.
But now Rockefeller
has been joined
by a whole host of
other organizations
like Gates, Gavi Initiative,
the PEPFAR, and so on.
So these are very
important players
in the global
public health field.
Another trend to bear in
mind is an increased role
for the pharmaceutical industry
in public health and medication
as a form of public
health intervention.
I said that public health
was a kind of reaction
against sickness services.
But in a sense,
the sickness idea
has come back into
public health.
It was there in terms of
interventions like vaccination
to prevent disease.
But now we have
medication as prevention
in a whole host of areas.
For example, think of statins
to prevent heart disease,
or think of methadone to
deal with drug addiction,
or nicotine to deal
with tobacco smoking.
And now, of course,
we've got PrEP,
which has been controversial,
to prevent HIV/AIDS.
So medication as prevention
is a whole new area
within public health.
And finally, of
course, public health
doesn't stay in
the same location.
In this country
recently, it's moved out
of the National Health Service
and back into local government.
And a lot of people in
the public health field
saw that as public
health coming home.
And they looked back to the
history of public health
and thought that
this was going to be
a golden age for public health.
Well, with all the cuts that are
going on in local government,
that hasn't quite
proved to be the case.
So I'll just finish
with a few thoughts.
I think we can finish
by saying, well,
what really is public health?
It's still a very broad arena.
And it's one that
does, as I said
at the beginning, change over
time, in terms of its focus.
We can ask, is it shaped
by the challenges it faces,
or is it shaped by the needs
of the professions that operate
within the public health field?
What exactly does it cover?
Some people have argued
that public health likes
technical fixes
and single issues,
because they're
easier to deal with.
And the Gates
Foundation, for example,
has been criticized for focusing
on vaccination immunization,
rather than broader programs
dealing with social inequality.
And that leads onto,
where should public health
focus its efforts?
Should it focus on
health services,
or should it focus on the
community at large and activity
and action within the community?
And finally-- and I think this
is probably very much the case
now--
is there a convergence
between issues
at the national, international,
and the global level?
Because many of those issues--
for example, chronic disease,
non-communicable disease,
antibiotic resistance, climate
change, and air pollution--
are not just issues for this
country or other countries,
but they are issues
which are being taken up
on the global stage, and
they affect people globally.
We were just in China before
Christmas in Beijing, Shanghai,
and other cities.
And the one thing
that struck us there
was how polluted the air was.
So air pollution, I think, is
very much of a global issue.
So I'll finish at that point.
As a historian, I cannot
predict the future.
So I have a cop-out there.
But I think
undoubtedly one thing
you can say about public
health is that it will
continue to change over time.
And the global impetus
behind public health, I think
will continue to become
increasingly important.
Anyway, thanks very much.
And I'm pleased to take
questions if you've got them.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you very much.
We do have time for questions.
So please.
AUDIENCE: You touched on mental
health with the Ryle quote.
Could you maybe say
a little bit more
about where approaches
to mental health fit in?
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: Yeah.
It's interesting mental
health figured so strongly
at that stage in the
1940s and the 1950s.
And looking at some of the
surveys which people did
from the School of
Hygiene in the 1950s,
mental health was very much a
key area within public health.
And I think it became
less prominent.
I suppose with the focus
on lifestyle and behavior,
public health moved in
different directions,
and only recently has mental
health started to come back
into the public health agenda.
In this country, still,
I think it's not really
defined as a public health
issue, not quite so centrally.
But certainly some
of my colleagues--
particularly one person, Vikram
Patel, who works in India--
is very much taking
up mental health
as a public health issue.
So I think it's coming back from
the global level, rather than
perhaps the national level.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: What can we
learn from the past,
in terms of educating the
public about the importance
of vaccines, because there
is an anti-vaccine narrative
that some people are
trying to run with?
And then perhaps
parallel to that, you
see people questioning
whether we should put fluoride
in the water.
Or today, the BMJ,
vitamin D meta-study
came out showing we should
all be taking vitamin D,
whereas in the US they add that
to milk and bread quite often.
So as a historian,
how would you perhaps
look at what we've tackled
issues like that in the past?
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE:
Well, first of all,
I think the broad issue
is the nanny state idea,
isn't it-- that is public health
advocating a nanny state where
everything is being
dealt with by the state?
And certainly, there's been
opposition to public health
initiatives on that basis.
And there's a constant
tension there,
I think, between the
rights of the individual
and the rights of the population
at large, which is very much
encompassed by
vaccination, isn't it,
where you're developing herd
immunity by having larger
numbers of people vaccinated.
So I think that's an ongoing
debate within public health
and within the community
more generally.
I think to some extent that's
not as strong as it was.
There used to be very strong
opposition to public health
as being busybody do-gooders
who wanted everyone
to behave and live in
the same sort of way.
But as public health has
broadened out recently
and then started to
encompass, again,
areas like air pollution
and global issues,
I think maybe that debate
has become less fraught
than it was.
In terms of vaccination,
I think there
is some interesting history to
bring into that, because there
was a very strong
anti-vaccination movement
in the 19th century, people
very opposed to vaccination.
And this was a popular movement.
It was a working class
movement, because vaccination
was seen as something which
people who were better off
could get out of.
It was seen as an
unsafe procedure that
often lead to side effects.
And there were also
cultural beliefs
about where vaccination
was coming from,
what it was doing to the body,
and so on, which were not
understood really at the time.
And I think often, sometimes
the anti-vaccination impetus
at the moment needs to
be understood, in a way,
rather than just condemned.
And very often in the
public health field,
I think people have tended to
argue that these people are
being duped, or it's false
science, or something
like that, whereas I
think there are probably
deeper cultural motives
and ideas which could
be teased out a little bit.
And that's something which has
also come up in the response
to the Ebola virus and in
Africa where people said,
if we'd understood a little bit
more about the cultural beliefs
from disease and so on, we
might have dealt with Ebola more
effectively initially.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I know you said
you're a historian.
But what role do you
see for technology
in public health going forward?
Can you see any ideas where
technology can play a role?
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: Yeah.
I think it's an
interesting area.
It depends how you
define technology.
There's the technology
of pills and medicines
and so on, which is very
much part of public health.
But there's also the
technology of self-monitoring
and monitoring your
steps and your heart
beat and your blood
pressure and so on.
And that has been discussed
very much in the public health
field, not just in
terms of the way
those technologies operate,
but also differential access
to technology.
So are you going to be getting
levels of the population
who are constantly
self-monitoring and able to do
that and then other
populations or other parts
of the population have no access
to that sort of technology
or have no cultural desire
to access that technology.
So yeah, I think
there certainly is
a lot of debate about the role
of technology in public health.
AUDIENCE: It might be
slightly off your field.
But is the funding
crisis in the NHS new,
or have we had things
like that in the past?
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: Well, it's
not entirely off my field.
One of the interesting
things about the changes
I talked about between
public health expected
to run a national
health service and then
not running a national health
service was that nobody really
costed out what the National
Health Service was going
to cost, because all the debates
before the Second World War
and during the Second
World War had made
the assumption that public
health was going to be funded
out of local rates or taxation
with a minimal input from--
well, not such a
big input, anyway--
from central government.
So that was one thing.
There was never any real costing
of what a national health
service would cost.
And I think the other point
was that people expected
that the National Health
Service would deal
with ill health
in the population
and that costs would go
down after a few years.
And they were really surprised
when costs actually went up.
So it wasn't until probably
nearly 10 years after the NHS
was established that
a committee was set up
called the Guillebaud
Committee, looking
at the costs of the
National Health Service.
And this has, more or less, been
an ongoing issue ever since.
Certainly it came to a crisis
point in the early 1970s
with the oil crisis, which
created a different situation
across the Western economies.
And so rationing
health services,
the cost of health services were
very much on the agenda then.
And really, they've
been on the agenda ever
since, because I think
as long as you've
got a centrally
tax-funded service,
costs are going to be a
political and a central policy
issue.
If you go to other
countries, they're
not talking about
their health services
in quite the same way
that we talk about ours,
because it is such a
political policy issue.
AUDIENCE: What do you
think of the legalization
of controlled substances,
particularly marijuana?
There was a big debate in
the US on that recently.
Does that go against the
direction of public health,
or does that make it easier
to change people's behavior
or something?
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: Oh,
that's a big topic.
Well, interestingly,
drugs and alcohol
were really outside the public
health area for a long while--
alcohol, because
it was so affected
by the temperance movement.
So alcohol was a temperance
topic for a long while
rather than a
public health topic.
And drugs-- and alcohol,
too, in some respects--
was seen as within the mental
health psychiatric area
rather than being a
public health topic.
But that came out
of that area a bit
and moved into public
health in the 1980s
when I think HIV/AIDS
and injecting drug use
made it much more of
a public health topic.
And then onto the
agenda at that stage
came something which we
still talk about called harm
reduction so that instead
of having a war on drugs,
you should have a preventive
attitude towards drugs
to try and prevent harmful use,
but not necessarily to prevent
all use whatsoever.
So that, broadly speaking, has
been the policy aim certainly
in this country, I think
less so in the United States,
and obviously even less so
in countries like Russia
which don't have harm
reduction at all,
in relation to drug use.
So a few years
ago, we would have
said that issues of
legalization are very far
from practical possibility.
But what's happened in
the States has rather
tended to disprove that, hasn't
it, where the local state
governments, the referenda
have been producing majorities
in favor of the
availability of cannabis,
either for medical purposes
or for more general use.
And that's a very
interesting situation.
How it will develop under
the current presidency,
I don't know.
It has been argued that
America, historically,
has been the key global power
arguing for a war on drugs.
It's been the leading proponent
of that war on drugs approach
across the globe.
And yet, within
its own boundaries,
it's actually contravening the
international drug conventions.
And that's been a very
interesting situation,
which Obama didn't
tangle with really.
But it will be interesting to
see what happens under Trump.
I'm afraid I have no inside
knowledge on that point.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So you have worked a lot
with policymakers, I think.
Can you say something
about how it
is different to do
the actual signs
and to derive
policies from that?
VIRGINIA BERRIDGE: Well,
there's been a big move
amongst historians
in the last 10,
15 years, I guess, to have
more impact on policy.
Now historians used to be,
they couldn't care less
about policy.
They just wanted to do their
own thing basically-- expand
the boundaries of knowledge.
But recently, I
think there's been
a greater move towards that.
A lot of discussion in
the historical field
about how you go about that.
And different modes
have been tried.
Some of my colleagues
are working
with different
government departments.
And they advise civil
servants in those departments.
Tony Blair, when he
was the prime minister,
used to get little discussion
groups together at number 10.
And in some of those
discussion groups,
there would be historians.
Well, obviously didn't
always take their advice.
And I think recently--
I was just talking to
somebody about this yesterday,
actually--
those sorts of
discussions go on.
There are connections
and lectures
by historians at number 10
right up to the present day.
But it is quite a
difficult relationship,
because policymakers
and politicians
are very much of the moment.
They don't have
that long-term view.
And in a sense, they disregard
the long-term view, really,
because they have to take
decisions here and now.
I shouldn't think the
long-term history of Europe
and the European
history, more generally,
is having much influence
on the Brexit negotiations.
But I may be wrong.
So I think historians
have to be careful
about their relationships
with policy, because it's
easy to have one's work
taken and used in a way which
one didn't necessarily intend.
But that's part of the nature
of policymaking, I think.
You have to be there
at the right moment
with the right message
at the right time.
And so it can be a
difficult relationship.
SPEAKER: Time for
one more question.
No question left?
Then please join me in thanking
Professor Virginia Berridge.
[APPLAUSE]